as epic fantasy adaptations for
television go the presumed king of the
dragon topped hill would seem to be
hbo's spectacularly successful game of
thrones even despite its polarizing
conclusion
why do you think i came all this way
clearly intending to cast a similar
spell over fans of the genre amazon's
recently launched big budget series the
wheel of time is off to an auspicious
start conquering nielsen's original
series streaming chart for november 16
through 21 and racking up a staggering
1.16 billion streaming minutes during
its premier outing with a total running
time of 169 minutes for its first three
episodes
the series clocked an average of seven
million viewers per episode based on the
beloved book series by author robert
jordan the story of a sprawling fantasy
realm ruled by magical powers both light
and dark took no less than 14 lengthy
novels to complete long considered
simply too complex expansive and
unwieldy to be contained in any tv or
film adaptation the series is populated
by some 2782
named characters and consists of an
eye-straining 4.1 million words and
while fans of the series seem pleased
overall with amazon's efforts to bring
the series to life on the small screen
there is one scene in the wheel of time
that some viewers think went too far
the wheel of time stars rosamund pike as
moraine a leading member of the
magically empowered eyes to die the
early episodes of season 1 follow
moraine and her companion land as they
travel with a small group of young
villagers beguine rand paren and matt
moraine believes one person in this
group is the dragon reborn a chosen one
who will either save the world or
destroy it the old blood runs deep in
those mountains
let's hope it's prepared them for what's
coming
audiences too should hope her theory
proves correct because we're told she
and lan have spent a long time searching
for this special person while every
member of this hallowed quartet of young
adult protagonists is worth tracking
throughout season 1. it's worth noting
that matt emerges as one dragon reborn
candidate to watch based on his behavior
in the first two episodes a poor
villager who is a bit of a rogue matt's
wily nature gets him and his traveling
companions into trouble when he makes a
fatal decision in episode two shadow's
waiting near the end of the episode
moraine sustains a near-fatal injury
that forces land to take the entire
group to shiddar lagoth a deserted city
where trouble lurks waiting to strike
while there lan instructs the group to
avoid touching or eating anything they
didn't bring with them as the city is
infected with latent evil and can awaken
to their presence should anyone interact
with an object left behind by the city's
residents
ignoring this sound advice
matt picks up and conceals what looks to
be a valuable dagger while wandering
through ruined buildings matt coffin's
decision to take a shadar lagoth dagger
is selfish but it has a larger impact on
his traveling group than he could have
predicted after matt takes the dagger a
darkness floods through the city
consuming any living matter it touches
this forces the group to split up with
rand and matt going in one direction
perrin and iguain going in another and
land forced to carry moraine out of the
city on horseback in yet another
direction fans responded vehemently on
twitter to this scene from the wheel of
time twitter user that aunt zelda wrote
oh matt oh why must you take the dagger
even my roommate knows nothing of wheel
of time and even they were like what are
you a dumb ass in that same vein meg
writes words agreed his behavior was
inexplicable chiming in with i do think
they're dumbing down character
motivation to a ridiculous degree matt
is poor and needs a new dagger so he
steals a ruby hilted dagger like we need
such an obvious hand-holding through
line
also complaining that the script's
deviation from the novels didn't give
enough warning about the city's innate
dangers yeshua 94 hume tweeted not
explaining why matt shouldn't take the
dagger come on all in all while the
series seems to be delivering on its
promise of fantasy on a larger than life
scale this is one scene in the wheel of
time a few fans thought went too far
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the wheel of time are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]